don't you just wish so
don't you just wish in your heart a
heart
some terry would come up in here trying
some grab ass and the touchy feely
that's
the opposite of what i want to have
happen on a plane okay that's
unfortunate
brothers
brothers let us begin
i have convened this meeting
to find out what you are doing
why have we not taken a plane
in 13 years
clean
you don't even know
it is all because the cunning and mighty
tsa
is always one step ahead of us i do not
believe it it's true
last month i attempted to take down a
plane with a pair of scissors five
inches long that sounds like a perfect
plan
why did it not work yes
in this shrewd
tsc
they made restrictions so you can only
take a four inch scissors
four inches what yes how could they know
that the five inch blade is a dangerous
weapon and the four inch plate is no
more than a child's play thing
that is the genius of tsa
they foil us at every turn devils
you know it's the same way with the
liquid what about the liquid
we all know how much devastation we can
wreak with 3.5 ounces of liquid damage
is incalculable the crafty tsa they have
limited passengers to only 3.4 ounces
damn it
do none of you have a solution how to do
for us to watch this tsa
it's like you've been living in a
well here look
the tsa they strike fear into my heart
with their polyester shirts and
disposable rubber gloves
and the the sneaker shoes
they are so clever
yes
they act as if they are listless
overweight employees who don't give a
[ __ ]
when in reality
they are an elite force
of anti-terrorist commandos oh curse the
brilliant tsa
religion if i may i think i have a way
to triumph over the wiley tfa finally
okay
i have a plan to put a bomb in a laptop
and it will get on it once you pull it
from its case
yes it is perfect
planes were running down from the sky
onto the infidels
[Music]
[Applause]
it's as if
the prophetic and all-knowing tsa
has predicted your plan
they make you take the laptop out of the
carrying case and put it in a separate
pin before you get on the plane come on
you've got to be kidding
me you've got to be kidding me are you
kidding me
this is not a funny joke every single
time you have time for kidding i
wouldn't kid this oh my god but god no i
don't believe these mothers of devils
yeah
well very wealthy
since all failed i will tell you how we
will destroy the non-believers
i have developed the smallest bomb
possible
and
it fits perfectly
into this
a full-sized
toothpaste
ah yes oh it's really great isn't it i
mean it's really fantastic what's going
on over here what's the situation over
here okay
is there a version of the toothpaste
bomb that comes in travel size
ah you know what it's like in our heads
look rasheed i'm gonna make this really
nice and easy for you i need names and
you're gonna give them to me you have to
listen to me you have to listen to me
this is all a huge mistake
department of homeland security's been
monitoring your calls for weeks regime
we got you
we know about you and your friends
we know that you're a terrorist
i am a terrorist
we me my friends we breed dogs
specifically terriers we write terrorist
fiction we we spend a good deal of time
discussing possible future terrorist
plots
this nice try
really is
but it's bull rasheed
come on is that the best you got what
now come on i'm listening just tell me
tell me
tell me about this imminent attack
what what what the title i don't know
what to do
what are you talking what am i talking
about i don't know huh huh i don't know
what you're talking about what are we
doing here no you don't know i don't
know i don't know june 11th rajid
you spoke of an imminent attack oh oh
yes
that was my friend listen his dog bit
him and i told him if you do not train
them another terrier attack is imminent
so you lied and you see what happens
come on regine i like you
let's be friends huh
now you still haven't explained to me
why we found on the search engine of
your computer the words target
washington 49 times that that is because
i was in dc for a dog show and i had to
buy a squeezy toy a birthday card and
some deodorant all at an affordable
price all right
you can only do that again yeah okay i
see how you want to play this
this is not a case ah mistaken identity
rajid oh and you know it
we've heard the conversations between
you and jafar were you discussing your
hatred of american ideas
american idols i hate them they were
voted
it was a desecration
my favorite band
we got you on tape referring to jafar as
one of the architects of seven eleven
it was seven eleven
[Music]
he designs convenience stores
7-eleven
wilson 65 dogs just attack the capitol
building were the terriers
how did you know
[Music]
okay there
burger says is
you
and sir if you could just wait for one
moment we are very very busy today i'm
so sorry
another great day of business brother
ibrahim are you kidding me look we are
raking in the money
line i have just bought a flat screen
television
really high definition we should watch
some of the american football club on
the screen i have the lazy boy i have
the lazy voiceover oh my god we can have
a listen
brother ibrahim brother osman
[Music]
what are you doing here in the united
states
a joyous surprise yes absolutely i was
just checking on your progress of course
this is a very good front for your
sleeper cell
the americans will never see it coming
they are totally fooled brother mustafa
they think that we're just two
immigrants who are in love with the
amazing
amounts of money that you can make being
entrepreneurs i mean this food truck is
like just printing money it's a little
crazy to be honest with you it's like a
bottomless pit of money you can just
reach in pull it out if you want when in
reality brother ibrahim yes we're in
reality we we want to destroy as many of
the imperialist infidels as possible
right
but what i don't understand is
you have your target you have your
explosives
why not just put the bomb on the truck
and then drive it straight into the
building carrying as many infidels as
you can
no so
the thing
is
that you're already doing it how is that
possible
[Music]
you say brother mustafa
this sandwiches
are loaded with cholesterol
slowly
the infidels they grow fat and their
arteries start to clog stop it and
i'm beginning to doubt
your dedication to the car no no no no
can i just order a fusion burger i'm
gonna hurry
uh yes
nine dollars please
our leaders will be very displeased did
you say nine dollars for one
uh yes yes and one one dollar extra for
crazy rock and hummus dip
how much do they cost to make uh
1050.50
pretty good margins
yes yes yes yes
how many do you sell a day
i don't know i don't know maybe 100 100
yes sometimes two good day maybe
200. yeah so the 200 is a big day
but you are ignoring your mission
you will pay the ultimate price no no no
no no no no no we are still
[Music]
okay that sounds good your order will be
right up uh that'll be nine dollars
please
my friends you must try mustafa kebab
only five dollars and one rock and roll
babaganoush wonder extra camera
don't focus
[Music]
yo
hey y'all
honyo
excuse me
oh man oh man oh man
i tell you one thing if 9 11's toward to
happen up on this airplane
don't worry
we got this
okay
okay i have no idea what you're talking
about
he's saying
that fdm terry's just gonna try some up
in here today like the bounce boogie and
bump
that we got dick
do you mean terrorist
help yeah baby he ain't talking about
terry guard and i certainly ain't
talking about no terry cloth
i mean if a terry up on this plane even
thinking about trying to do something
we're gonna wax him
up
you you're gonna you're gonna what we're
gonna drax
know
slouched
i think what my partner's trying to say
if if any terrorists come up in here we
gonna get our bergeron
did something happen or did i
miss something is hypothetical or oh
we're going to definitely drop some
hypotheticals on that terry's clavicle
because i'm talking about
squeeze squeeze squeeze squeeze
don't you just wish so
don't you just wish in your heart a
heart
some terry would come up in here trying
some grab ass and the touchy feely
that's
the opposite of what i want to have
happen on a plane
okay that's unfortunate
conference
this was unexpected it certainly was
i'm thrown right now as to who's gonna
be our comrade he can still hear you
doesn't have the heart not a gumption
you're literally right next to me oh
three
break
three
you who
ah i got an idea feel free to say no but
can we switch seats i will not take no
for an answer
why
that's the combat seat jonathan
livingston's ego
if you to be in the combat seat
then you got to be willing to blast up
on some carries
because the great power
comes great response of trilogy
okay i just i just wanted some leg room
um
okay max leg room
you get yours
meanwhile
i'm gonna go hayden pantanieri on some
terries especially when they get froggy
rip it ribbit
um you don't have to be ready to kidnap
a terry i don't you're gonna have to be
ready to touch you i carry i don't think
that's necessary absolutely you have to
fireboard those mother jammers
i don't even understand what that means
do you trust me no
i'll take that at the yeah okay
trust
these terries come up in here
trying to act froggy
then we gonna give them the rainbow
connection yeah
so won't get from getting from there
frog box cutter oh you best believe it
baby
we gonna be eating
like diane keaton
2.35 inches baby [ __ ] wax
perfectly league well
and if those don't work
you know i'm working up that plan b
brother
3d printer baby 100
polyurethane they can't detect these
mammal generals
that's what they they have a weapon they
have a weapon
okay
[Music]
drax
hello scouts
[Music]